a case of alleged child abuse at an  Arizona migrant shelter will be referred  to a local district attorney today for  possible criminal charges the arizona  republic' obtained surveillance videos  that appear to show children being  dragged pushed and hit by staff at the  southwest key shelter the alleged  incidents took place in September about  a month before the shelter was closed  the Maricopa County Sheriff's Office  told CBS News it investigated the  incidents and decided to submit the case  to the Maricopa County Attorney's Office  that's after deciding at first that  there were no grounds for a criminal  referral Southwest Key has said it was  engaging in an independent review of the  processes procedures hiring and training  at its arizona shelters